[Música]
hola todos ustedes saben que las
computadoras funcionan con ceros y con
un acierto porque lo hemos visto en
películas porque lo hemos visto en
series porque lo hemos visto en cultura
popular todo el mundo habla que son cero
y en uno pero nosotros no necesariamente
sabemos por qué porque es un cero en uno
porque en un dos por qué no en tres
porque no hay cero un dos tres
la razón es porque toda nuestra
computación funciona con electricidad y
electricidad pasa por cables y si no hay
electricidad es un cero y si hay
electricidad es un 1 eso es todo y si yo
12 cables no tengo un 2 tengo la misma
cantidad ectr incidentes también tengo
un 1 por alguna razón no nos enseñan
esto no nos enseñan el porqué de esto es
un cero y uno el porqué de muchas de
estas profesiones y arrancar por
software es fácil pero porque me imagino
que muchos de ustedes son afines con
esto pero por ejemplo ustedes saben en
diseño gráfico porque usan esta ruedita
la ruedita de color y de dónde es que
salen las paletas de colores cuando
están tratando de crear una paleta para
el diseño de un póster para el diseño un
sitio web o lo que sea resulta que una
serie de figuras
las matemáticas que dependiendo de la
posición donde nosotros las coloquemos
dentro de la ruedita y como ajustemos el
brillo del color se ven mucho mejor y
podemos extraer esa paleta y esta es la
base de muchos de los fundamentos de
diseño y ustedes pueden llegar ahí
tratando entender pero porque esto es
naranja porque esto es azul porque
colocar nuestra tipografía
otra muy común es cuando ustedes creen
que el celular quién de ustedes cree que
el celular los está escuchando y les
pone anuncios dependiendo de lo que
hablan por favor levantar la mano o que
el resto no están siendo honestos eso
está bien eso está bien
les pasa que ustedes hablan con otro
oigan miren estos tenis que me compré
tenis marca plata sí y entonces de
repente en todas partes le empiezan a
salir anuncios y uno esta vaina ve está
espiando cuando lo que realmente ocurre
es que no necesitan tener tu micrófono
como tú has salido en fotos con otros
amigos y yo ya tiene una conexión muy
fuerte que probablemente ustedes son
amigos o tienen algún tipo de relación
entonces todo el comportamiento de
compra que tenga uno como ustedes son
muy similares y pasan en lugares
parecidas de acuerdo a las cookies a la
ip al gps el celular etcétera entonces
implica que ustedes son un perfil de
consumir similares les muestra anuncios
similares eso es todo no tienen por qué
saber no tienen por qué aprender el
micrófono y este es otro problema este
es uno de esos casos donde nosotros ya
dejamos de preguntarnos el porqué y en
vez de preguntarnos por qué lo que
hacemos es entrar en la conclusión abajo
es porque el celular me está escuchando
esto para mí es uno de mis favoritos
ustedes saben porque el número pi 3 14
15 92 65 blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah finalmente que esto es una
audiencia del tps montería seguro que
muchos de ustedes saben pero imaginando
que no porque a mí no me enseñaron a mí
simplemente el profesor me dijo esto es
pi hágale estas son todas las ecuaciones
del álgebra de baldor y pues yo le hice
pero resulta que con el pasar del tiempo
descubrí que si ustedes trazan una raya
con valor 1 y dibujan un círculo
eso es el diámetro cierto del radio el
círculo perdón el diámetro del doble lo
transportan y luego lo pega en el borde
del círculo y eso es un radial
entonces cuando se tiraron álgebra en
octavo noveno fue por esto un radio
luego si ustedes lo suman soy yo me tiré
álgebra no sé dos radiales tres radiales
y el pedacito que sobra eso es pi por
eso y es una constante universal porque
así es de donde sale pi 3,14 15 bla bla
bla bla bla y uno lo puede calcular y
aún no simplemente llega ahí
preguntándose por qué porque nosotros
llegamos a cada una de estas cosas
el por qué es una pregunta que nosotros
perdemos muy temprano en nuestra
educación hay un gráfico muy famoso de
cómo funciona la educación en el mundo y
es que imaginen que ese círculo negro es
el conocimiento total de la humanidad
entonces arrancan y estudian en la
escuela donde están más llenos de porque
es luego dependiendo del país puede que
sabían una preparatoria antes de la
universidad eventualmente llegan a la
universidad donde les toca a ojo y en
una edad muy joven y llena de
complicaciones elegir carrera y puede
que elijan la carrera equivocada pero
imaginamos que eligiera la carrera
correcta entonces aumentan su
conocimiento y empiezan a obtener
conocimiento específico conocimiento
especializado y luego algunos de ustedes
van a hacer un máster que les va a
generar el máximo conocimiento de esa
área y luego si le dedican otros cinco
años a los 15 años que ya llevan
estudiando unas en un page de iu
aumentan un poquitito el conocimiento
humano y esto es un gran sistema
funciona muy muy bien pero tiene una
serie de problemas el principal problema
es que si ustedes imaginan una vida a
cualquiera normal significa que ustedes
pasan 11 años estudiando cosas básicas
luego 5 años siendo muy profesionales
otros 5 súper profesionales trabajan
34 años a los 60 se compran un porcino
se mueren y así es como todo el mundo
vive en la vida
eso implica que si ustedes siguen por el
camino normal de toda la vida a los 26
años es cuando de repente ustedes
empiezan a tener una carrera profesional
empiezan a ver qué es lo que quieren
hacer y qué pasa y estos 26 años no la
verdad es que a mí no me gustaba el
derecho es que mi papá era abogado
entonces eso es un problema y es un
problema del cual nosotros no nos
alejamos porque está súper mal visto a
nivel social que nos salgamos del
caminito que nos pusieron nuestros
padres no usted vaya a la universidad y
va a hacer esto y se va a casar y esta
casa y el programa mío
y la razón por la que nosotros nos
aterra salirnos de ese track es también
una razón histórica por cifras porque
nos dicen usted no va a ganar mucho
excepto si va a la universidad e
históricamente eso ha sido verdad hasta
hacer los últimos cinco años esto es un
estudio del el salario que tienen
desarrollar es de software ha hecho por
software grupo este año ellos detectaron
que las desarrollarás de software que
van a la universidad ganan 36 por ciento
más que los que aprenden online entonces
esto suena que claro eso es lo normal es
lo que me han dicho toda la vida porque
resulta que la educación online y la
educación alternativa nos lleva mucho
tiempo con nosotros entonces nosotros
regulamos solamente las personas que
llevan menos de cinco años en el mercado
sean que se dieron cuenta en esta
encuesta que la diferencia es de más o
menos el 1% o sea una persona grado la
universidad ganan más o menos 1% más un
poquito más de 1% la diferencia no es
mucha
cuando le agregan a esto que sepan más
inglés con mayor eficiencia el 70 por
ciento no importa donde han aprendido
porque la diferencia de menos del 1%
pero solamente hecho es saber inglés
aumenta la probabilidad de aumentar su
salario un 40 por ciento sólo por
en inglés entonces la diferencia no es
tanta y el mundo cambio la razón es
porque nosotros en latinoamérica tenemos
640 millones de personas de ellas 150
millones están en edad o condiciones
para buscar formación profesional para
buscar una escuela técnica la
universidad de un camino alternativo lo
que sea de esas 150 millones sólo 20
millones tienen acceso a la universidad
porque la universidad es un privilegio y
el universidad implica que ustedes
nacieron en la familia correcta en la
ciudad correcta y están en las
condiciones correctas personales para
poder lograrlo y porque es esta cantidad
de sillas que hay incluso si los
gobiernos hicieran el esfuerzo más
inmenso para duplicar la cantidad de
universidades y sillas que existen
tendrían 40 y que harían todavía 110
millones buscando formación esto en
contraste con que el año pasado en
latinoamérica quedaron 1.5 millones de
empleos vacantes en la economía digital
en cualquier cosa que tenga que ver con
crear con tecnología 1 que hay 1.5
millones de empleos sino que 1.5
millones de empleos en toda
latinoamérica vacíos en colombia en
particular fueron 100 mil
más importante son los datos de la ocde
la organización que se dedica a medir la
pobreza el avance a la educación
etcétera en nuestros países ellos
terminan que toma de cinco a siete
generaciones salir de pobre eso
significa que yo soy pobre mi hijo es
pobre mi nieto es pobre mi tratamiento
es pobre mi tatara tatara nieto empieza
a tener esperanza en nuestros países en
latinoamérica
nosotros en plan si tenemos al día de
hoy 700 mil estudiantes y hemos hecho un
seguimiento de qué pasa cuando ellos le
dedican mucho tiempo a su aprendizaje y
cuánto es lo mínimo detectamos con ayuda
de omidyar network y acumen cuando
hicimos un reporte impacto el año pasado
que aquellos que le dedican un año
enfocado a aprender de alguna capacidad
o característica técnica alguna carrera
relacionada con tecnología un año
después tienden a aumentar sus ingresos
de 54 260 por ciento pero más importante
estas son personas que después de
estudiar en un año se movieron de
pobreza a clase media media-alta a
volverse los principales proveedores de
sus familias esto es algo que sólo
ocurre con educación y solamente ocurre
con educación escalable no ocurre de
ninguna otra
forma en vez de que cinco generaciones
tome a ellos les toma 23 años
esto significa que vivimos en un futuro
en el que el 13% de la población en edad
o condiciones van a la universidad y el
87 por ciento del resto del talento van
a usar otros medios para aprender
esto es importante en particular por las
circunstancias nosotros estamos ahora
mismo en nuestra civilización
este es un gráfico creado por el
director del laboratorio innovación de
google google ex y exl apps los que
crearon el automóvil que se conduce solo
etcétera él menciona que nuestra
tecnología humana está avanzando y
volviéndose más compleja a una velocidad
mucho más rápida de la que el cerebro
humano se puede adaptar lo más
interesante es que él cuenta que este
punto donde ya nosotros no podemos
mantenernos respecto a tratar de
entender toda la innovación humana es un
punto en el que llegamos en los 90s y
que hoy estamos acá
no solamente estamos acá la aceleración
de la innovación es mucho más alta de
nuestra capacidad de aprender los
humanos aprenden un humano de 1.818 sabe
mucho menos que un niño de 15 años de
nuestra época pero no crecemos al ritmo
el que crece en nuestra innovación eso
significa que la única esperanza que
nosotros tenemos para mantenernos en
este nuevo mundo es abandonar la idea de
que no va una sola vez a la universidad
uno monetiza esa carrera de por vida y
luego ya está eso fue lo que uno hizo en
cambio necesitamos una actitud de nunca
parar de aprender
necesitamos una actitud en la que
después de la educación básica en la que
no me meto es un problema muy complicado
cambiar todo lo que tiene que ver con
primaria y bachillerato pero asumiendo
que todo eso sale bien once años después
imaginen un mundo en el que ustedes por
esos 44 años de vida
[Aplausos]
productiva algunos tendrán más otros
menos en teoría nosotros podemos vivir
hasta más de 100 años miren la charla de
un minuto
son 44 años de nunca parar de aprender
en esos 44 años ustedes podrían tener de
10 a 15 profesiones e incluso solamente
tienen 2 o 3 los mejores fundadores de
las empresas más grandes del planeta
siempre lo fueron porque combinaron dos
o tres disciplinas distintas los mejores
y más deseados profesionales siempre
tienden a ser las personas que aunque se
especializan en algo tienen múltiples
conocimientos que en esa intersección de
disciplinas es donde se crean las
innovaciones más interesantes en los que
comprar un tesla y se van a marte en
spacex con hilos mosca pero eso no es lo
importante lo importante es entender que
el camino que nos pintaron toda la vida
fue verdad para nuestros padres y fue
verdad para muchas personas de otras
generaciones pero en este punto vivimos
en un mundo que va a ser cada año más
radicalmente distinto eso significa que
por más de que ustedes quieran seguir la
carrera toda la vida busquen otros
caminos alternativos busquen aprender de
arte a pesar de que sean biólogos
marinos busquen aprender de programación
a pesar de que odian las matemáticas
porque es en esa intersección donde
nació machine learning donde nacieron
los automóviles que se conducen solos
donde ha nacido mucho el arte
interactivo y donde los mejores
del futuro es donde viven y por supuesto
no pierdan eso que nosotros decimos a
los niños que se callan no pierdan en
preguntar el porqué de todo porque todo
tiene un porqué y cuando ustedes llegan
a esa profundidad ustedes llegan a esa
filosofía y ese pensamiento que nunca en
lo largo de sus vidas para de aprender
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]